so how many people here work with an MVC
framework of some sort where you find
yourself regularly observing model data
and trying to update UI and keep it sort
of in sync so how many people so almost
everybody in this room that's fantastic
so today I'm going to talk about
something I consider to be a little bit
of a butterfly it's a proposed method
for the next version of JavaScript
called object.observe which aims to
bring true data observation to the
browser now object.observe is also known
as o.o whereas some people like to say
ooh right so before the end of this talk
I'm hoping that you're going to be as
excited about object observ as I am um
if not I'm going to talk a little bit
more about butterflies so when we talk
about data observation um what do we
mean well we're usually talking about um
observing changes to Raw JavaScript
objects so things like you know when are
properties getting added changed and
deleted when are arrays having elements
like being spliced in and out of them
and and sort of so on now you might be
wondering well why do we actually care
about observing data changes at all well
the short answer to that is model view
control separation now as we can see
here HTML is like this really great
decorative mechanism it's but it's
completely static um and ideally you
just want to be able to declare the
relationship between your data and the
Dom and keep the Dom up to date that
creates a nice amount of Leverage and it
saves you a lot of time writing what's
really repetitive boiler plate code
which really just sends data to and from
sort of you know the Dom between your
apps internal server or the apps
internal State now for people trying to
solve this problem what does the world
look like today well many people end up
relying on things like two-way data
binding um in Solutions like angular
this is done um using dirty checking and
the basic idea there is that anytime
data could have changed you go and you
scan if it did change and the benefit
there is that you really get to use like
nice raw JavaScript object data it
composes quite well one of the downsides
is that it actually has pretty poor
algorithmic behavior and it's
potentially very expensive now that
expense is actually proportional to the
number of objects that you're observing
and you may end up needing to do quite a
lot of dirty checking um there are
actually quite a few nice clever tricks
that framework authors use to try
working around this but it's unclear if
it's ever really going to be
perfect so let's load up a quick example
um of an angular app so here we've got a
very single um angular app uh it's got
sort of a phone controller and we've got
a phone model so we're just iterating
over that and and rendering sort of a
phone name and a phone
snippet and we're just binding
properties from sort of that phone model
that's an angulars the Dom um that's
being rendered now if we wanted we could
actually reach down um into the scope of
this model um for our phone items and
actually update them so we can go and we
can replace this and say okay well um
maybe we want to replace the uh the
phones array here with something a
little bit more JS comfy like the Next
Generation tablet for cats the JS com
3000 so as you can see it's gone and
it's updated um and it's now in sync so
the model date the model State and
what's um in the Dom is actually up to
date but this is actually achieved um
using dirty
checking um we can actually go um and
take a look at another example so we've
looked at Ang angular um we can go look
at Ember as well well so let me load up
a very quick example for that so Ember
uses um event Loops or I guess what I
call container objects and the idea with
container objects are where Frameworks
create objects which sort of on the
inside hold the data um and then they
then have sort of accessors to that data
and uh they can sort of capture what you
set or get um and then sort of
internally broadcast what's happening um
now the flip side of this is it actually
works quite well um It's relatively
performant it's got fairly good um
algorithmic behavior um but the expense
is uh of sort of discovering what
changed is proportional to the number of
changes uh that sorry the number of
things that
changed now this introduces another
problem um you're no longer working with
just raw JavaScript data you're actually
working with a completely different kind
of object and you normally end up having
to convert any data coming back from
sort of your server or your API to these
custom objects so that they're then
observable um this doesn't compose
particularly well um with existing
JavaScript code because most of it's
going to end up relying on the fact that
you know you're just working with raw
data um and that would be slightly more
ideal so ideally you don't want to be
working with specialized objects um this
is another example let me uh load it up
very quickly so this is backbone which
doesn't actually have a concept of
two-way data binding in fact if you
wanted to get it in place you'd have to
to hack together your own sort of traps
to get this set up or or use a plugin of
some sort now my firm belief is that the
web platform can evolve and innovate to
to solve some of the problem problems
around these areas and provide us with a
slightly better decorative mechanism um
for solving things like perhaps
constraint-based model systems and uh
maybe Auto persistent systems as well uh
we're going to take a look at some
examples of what that actually means
quite
soon now um the solution that we're
proposing to this uh is object.observe
um I kind of wish that uh that this was
the official logo for it it's just it's
kind of nice um but ideally what we like
is the best of both worlds uh we like to
be able to work with raw JavaScript
objects if we can um and we don't want
to have to necessarily dirty check every
single time we think that data has
changed we also want something that has
fairly good algorithmic behavior and
composes quite well so let's talk about
what we can actually observe so we've
talked about the idea of uh sort of
observing an object uh let's imagine
that we go and we mutate a property on
that object what we get back with
object.observe is sort of a Change
Report of what changed um and you can
find out what properties have been added
when they've been deleted when
something's been sort of reconfigured uh
this is sort of a very simple sort of
to-do object and we can also find out
when something's been updated as well as
any changes that have been made to the
Prototype
chain um so we can find out about data
properties and and all sorts of things
and this is is actually quite a a nice
way of um of approaching this
problem so let's take a look at an
actual examples this is an extremely
trivial example of of using object.
observe um and the idea here is that
we're basically um observing a a
fictional object called OB as first
parameter first argument um the second
argument is basically a call back which
returns all of our change records so if
we iterate over our change records what
you'll see returned um is a list of
different interesting things so it
Returns the change type so is the change
new updated deleted or reconfigured um
it actually Returns the affected object
the uh affected property name as well as
the old value now this is great but um
what we probably want to do is look at a
real example so I'm just going to flip
on over to another example very quickly
so here we have sort of a uh a a very
simple to-do application we have a a raw
JavaScript object representing our
to-dos we have another sort of uh
Observer here and we're basically just
observing our to-do
model let's go and just evaluate this
code so we can um we can play around
with it so I'm just going to clear the
console very quickly now um let's say
we've got a label that says default
let's go and modify that label so I'm
just going to say okay well let's change
that label to say buy some more milk for
example now what we get back is this
nice change record um representing all
the changes that occur so the change
type here is updated and if we go to the
affected object this actually provides
us with our expected state of the world
um it says the label is what we uh set
it to which is great we can actually go
and actually uh introduce new properties
to this object as well so I'm going to
introduce completed by here so uh
completed by first first 2014 um expand
that object and you'll see is that we
now have a change type of new so we're
introducing new properties into this and
once again as expected um our view of
the world is is is as expected which is
great we can also go and start deleting
properties uh from this object so let me
get the casing right uh so we can delete
the to-do models completed property and
when we expand the object here you can
see that the change type now is actually
deleted and uh we can of course um also
expand that object and uh just confirm
um that our assumptions are correct so
so that works as
well now I mentioned object.observe now
there's actually a complimentary method
called object. unobserved which allows
us to sort of halt our observation of an
object so here I've gone and I've
stopped um observing to do model using
the Observer we defined earlier and when
I go and I make any modifications to
properties of this object now um so I'm
just going to so say buy some more beer
um you'll see that we no longer get any
change records
back so that's actually pretty nice um
the next thing we're going to take a
look at uh is actually um how this fits
in s we're looking sort of data
observation with data binding so here we
have an example of a very simple app and
the idea is that you sort of uh you can
rotate the different items in this list
um and just sort of animate uh this is
using polymer which is sort of a
framework based on web components it's a
little bit similar to angular or Ember
it has a something a little bit like an
NVC mechanism and it's using
object.observe behind the
scenes now what's of particular interest
to us here um is the template tag first
of all this basically lets us de clear
in HTML inner Dom fragments and it's a
little bit of a nicer alternative to
JavaScript templating what we've got in
the background is sort of template
binding which describes how this
template tag manages instances and we
have another feature called node. bind
which actually describes how Dom nodes
can be bound to uh to data
values so uh in here we see that we also
have sort of this uh this repeat um
attribute and the idea is basically that
it maintains a binding for every element
that's inside of an array collection
when it's provided so in this case
colors um now onto the stuff that we
probably care about um if you want to to
activate a template you actually do that
by sating um setting sort of a data
model on it and this goes and it causes
any bind repeat or if attributes that
you have in your template to begin
acting um we can actually do this with a
with model. colors it's just a simple
colors array and if you wanted you could
actually go and start pushing new colors
to it uh now we get on to this point
where we've got this uh this concept
called platform. perform microtask
checkpoint which is an extremely verose
name for something um but it actually is
just really doing dirty checking so in
polymer at least for platforms that
don't natively support um object.observe
uh dirty checking still is done and so
that you get this nice sort of cross
browser uh way of doing things um and
the way this works is that you know when
you run it it actually has to go and
discover okay well there's a new color
that's been pushed and then it needs to
go and check all the potential places
that data could have been changed um and
it needs to be told that now Frameworks
use this so angular does something a
little bit similar like this but other
Frameworks are like a little bit clever
about it so what we can actually go do
um now is uh is go and play around
around with our model a little bit um so
the first thing we do is we go and uh we
can sort of copy that selector we had
earlier just to select the list that
we're working against um I just go and
copy paste that into uh the
console and then I can start interacting
with my model so here I'm just going to
push um into our colors array a new
color and it's just going to be uh
Indigo and hopefully so there we go it's
been pushed into uh the list and I can
go and I can rotate it so that works
absolutely fine there's nothing too
crazy about that um what we can actually
also do is because we're working in
Canary at the moment and I have
object.observe turned on um I can go and
I can disable these platform uh dirty
check uh operations and we can go do the
the pretty much the exact same thing
once again just to see uh it working
with object.observe so just going to
expand the the console out once again um
and try out what we were
doing so we're just going to go and uh
select colors and then we're going to
push a new color to it maybe uh
Orange
and as you can see it shows up right
away and basically this gives us a
really nice way of sort of mutating this
data um and keeping the Dom following
along with us and the idea is really
just to pinpoint when data changes um
are occurring and just react to to what
changes are there in a very nice
way um I actually have another example
uh of where we can bind to input
elements so the idea here is that we
have two um sort of input Fields let me
load up the source for it we have two
input Fields um and these are basically
bound to some um model data and whenever
I make changes to these input Fields um
we're basically saying okay we're going
to keep this value in sync across both
our model and the Dom once again we're
using um sort of a template here and in
this case we're just binding to an
object called input on our model um and
we're just providing values of of amount
to to both of those input fields and we
can actually scroll down once again
you'll see that um this is sort of the
representation of our model um and the
amount and uh I guess again because
we're in Canary we can actually disable
the dirty checks just to just to make
sure that we're we're actually using the
nice web platform goodness that this
comes
with so uh we can actually go and start
um mutating uh the input amount so I can
go and I can just select the input once
again I can say okay well t. model. uh
input uh. amount and then I can just
change it to a new value so 50 and
you'll see that instantly um the values
in our UI are are are just updated right
away without us having to do anything
this isn't using dirty checking it's
just using object. observe which is
quite nice um and another nice thing is
that we can actually take this a little
bit further so um I actually uh took the
colors example and combined it with some
sort of web audio and and some canvas
animation um and so we end up with
something like this where we're actually
able to um once again just push colors
into an array and and have it uh sort of
um reflect in our UI so
hopefully so basically this is working
against um a collection of different
colors and we're able to reach down into
the model um of these colors and
actually change it so here in this case
I'm setting the the color colors that
are available to just orange and purple
and what you should see in just a moment
um is that any of the new objects being
created on screen are actually going to
be um either a shade of orange or or a
shade of purple and this is just being
um achieved using object. observe behind
the scenes observing any sort of changes
to this object um we can go and we can
set set other colors so maybe blue and
green and uh so you should hopefully see
lots of blue and green looking things
appearing most of these look like Tic
Tacs for some reason
um but yeah it it works it's kind of
nice we got this constant view of the
world which uh which I kind of
like so next let's take a look at an
example of uh persistence so this is
sort of the world's like simplest
persistence um system it doesn't really
do that much we could imagine a
persistent system um which saves the
state of your data directly to something
like index DB your local storage or file
system so what I'm doing here is I'm
sort of creating a new uh function class
called Fu um and then I'm just going to
see if persist be my local sort of
database can go and retrieve an instance
of this and of course we haven't really
used it before so it's not going to do
anything crazy I'm just going to
redeclare that um and then I have sort
of this records away which uh sort of
represents a serialized version of a
collection of these FS I can actually
now go and and push a new Foo onto it um
and interact with this array in in
really any way I want it's gone and it's
um automatically saved it to dis I can
go and I can start adding additional
properties and the nice thing about this
is that uh is that when I reload this
demo um there we go my data uh should be
in the record so I'm just going to
redeclare my function um Fu and uh then
check inside persist TB so I'm going to
create my new records array once again
and try retrieving our data and what
you'll see is that it actually persisted
all of the data that we were uh working
with before um that happen to come
through our change record so that's
quite nice we have another example um
here of a sort of a constraint mechanism
so uh let me let me load this up um
stretch out the window a little bit so
what we have here here is a sort of a
circle um and the circle has got sort of
a circle circle function or Circle class
I've loaded up a constraint library in
the background and there are actually
three properties on this circle that
probably look familiar so we have a
radius a circumference and uh and an
area and they're using functions that
probably also look a little bit similar
now the constraint mechanism here um is
basically just representing these using
methods which resolve data going in one
direction or another um and what I can
actually go and do here is uh go and
create a circle and uh so Circle five
and what it's G and has done it's
actually um resolved the radius to
assign values to sort of the
circumference and the area um and if I
if I actually go back to this um I can
actually update the area and this ends
up resolving uh both the radius and the
circumference um as we can see there so
that's working um and it happens to be
one way of doing sort of computed
properties uh when you know sort you
sort of want one property to be
dependent on another property and people
care about this in MVC framework because
it's actually something quite nice um
and in this casee pretty much all the
properties are are somewhat
interdependent um and they're basically
being resolved depending on the property
you're assigning to so in some ways the
circle is sort of observing itself
internally um and it's just a nice view
of the world so here we have sort of a
yet another um I guess another
observation mechanism it's sort of an
MVC app and it really brings together
the uh the two things we were just
looking at sort of sort of persistence
and constraint and the idea here is that
I can go and I can create a new Circle
um it saved for me right away I can
actually go and set a radius I can
change the area and as you can see the
properties are instantly recomputed um
across everything which is which is
quite nice um and everything's
automatically saved I can go and I can
create any new Circle I want I can
actually go and
delete now one thing to notice here um
is because of the timing of the way that
object out observe works you end up
having quite a lot of power over the way
that things work um in fact to to sort
of illustrate this um I can go in and uh
start to modify uh the way that this
circle works so I can modify each of the
circles that you see here on and
increase the radius by a power of two so
I'm just going to go and uh select the
template that we're working
against and uh template do model do
circles do iterate over
it do some more not very sexy stuff c.
radius multiply by
two and that should be
good and basically what you see here is
that the resolver updated the internal
properties of each of these circles
um and then our persistence mechanism
sort of saw that the two circles changed
and so it serialized them to dis as this
single transaction now if you missed it
we can actually um sort of go back and
and make further modifications to this
but it's it's actually quite nice um
you're able to very easily control the
flow of all these different properties
and and just keep them in sync and it
gives you a nice way of just treating
lots of changes as sort of a single
transaction it's a very consistent view
of the world and it's it's pretty
desirable now another interesting thing
about object.observe um is that you
actually have control over over um what
you want to be able to to to find out
information about so in this case we've
got our to-do model once again um and
I'm actually able to say well I'm only
interested in uh changes of a specific
type so in this case I've got a third
argument with uh sort of an array and
I've said okay well I'm only interested
in uh deleted changes and uh what I can
do here is actually go and demonstrate
this by changing the label so we're just
going to say okay well the label is buy
some beer and you'll notice that there's
been no change records returned for it
but if I go and I delete my to-do model
um label you'll see the change records
return um and this just gives you a lot
of control over over what you're
interested in which is which is quite
nice um and if you know if you don't
sort of provide that third argument what
it does is it defaults to the intrinsic
types so things like you know new and
updated and reconfigured and so on um
object. observe also supports this idea
of sort of a single call back Observer
and you could do this if you wanted um
it basically means that you can use a
single call back to observe um a lot of
different objects and uh sort of the
call back is going to be delivered uh
sort of the aggregate changes from from
all of your different processes um and
this sort of happens at the end of the
microtask and it just gives you a flow
that's a little bit like mutation
observers which is quite
nice um now the next thing we want to
talk about um is sort of notifications
Now notifications are a little bit
similar to mutation observers they
happen at the end of your microtask um
and in the browser context this is
pretty much always going to be at the
end of sort of the current event handler
um and the the timing is uh it's the
timing is a little bit nice because
generally sort of you have one unit of
work that's finished and then your
observers can go and do whatever they
need to get done and it's a very nice
sort of turn-based processing model now
you'll see a note up here about sort of
synchrony um and I say you know
synchronous delivery would create a
dangerous processing model The
Experience on the web platform is that
synchronous is usually the first thing
that you end up doing because it's it's
fairly easy to do it's fairly easy to
wrap your head around um async tends to
be harder but I think in the long term
it tends to be uh to be worth it it's a
better model in my opinion
so the next thing we're to talk about is
uh sort of accessor properties so most
observation systems end up wanting some
form of um way to sort of observe
derived values and there are quite a few
different ways that you could go about
doing this um I mentioned earlier uh
that sort of um only the value of
changes that are observable for data
properties are something you can look at
and it's not really something that you
can do with sort of computed Properties
or accessors um and there's an
interesting reason for behind this so
the reason is that JavaScript um doesn't
really have the notion of of changes um
in value to accessors and uh an accessor
is really just a collection of functions
if you think about it if you go and you
sort of assign something to an accessor
it uh sort of really just invokes um the
function there and from its point of
view nothing's really changed um it just
gave some um other functionality the
ability to go and and run uh so we have
an example here a very simple um setup
and the problem is semantically so I
have I'm basically defining um a
property called Val on my object and
then going and I'm assigning to Val of
value five semantically we can sort of
look at this assignment um and you know
think that it has some meaning um and we
be ought to be able to know what
actually happened here but the problem
is that there's no real way for any
system to know what this actually means
I mean it can't automatically determine
that Val is something meaningful to the
system and that um it should be able to
tell other parts of the system that this
is something of Interest or that
there're a particular pieces of data
around this that it should be informing
other um bits and pieces about so we're
updating the value every time time it's
accessed and accessing what this change
means currently doesn't really have a
huge amount of meaning the solution to
this problem um is something that we
call synthetic change records and the
idea um is basically if you want to have
um sort of accessors or computed
properties it's your responsibility to
notify when their values go and change
and uh object. observe gives you a
relatively nice API for doing this um so
imagine that we have an object of some
sort now inside that object we have a
concept of a system that let let us go
and Define notifications so you are able
to go and notify um other observers of a
particular set of changes that are sort
of um relevant to to your model so in
this case we're just saying okay well
the type is updated the name is radius
and the old value is 10 now basically
the object is able to say well anything
relevant to my implementation that I
want to go report to to other people um
I can do so it's a it's a little bit of
extra work um but it's designed as sort
of a first class feature of this
mechanism and these notifications end up
being sort of delivered with the rest of
notifications from the system um so from
your like data properties so let's take
a look at an example of this um so uh
let me load this up very quickly so the
idea here is that we basically have a
circle and there's sort of a radius
property here um in this case the radius
is sort of an accessor um and when its
value changes it's actually going to go
and notify for yourself that the value
changed um now this is going to be
delivered with all the other changes
this object or sort of any other object
now notice that we have a Notifier here
so we have this concept of a Notifier
which is is then able to notify any of
its observers about specific changes
that it knows they may be interested in
so you have a lot of control over what
this object is able to tell the rest of
the system so if you're implementing an
object and you want to have sort of
synthetic or computed properties you're
going to have to pick a strategy for how
this works for you um once you do um
you'll find this this actually fits
quite nicely into into most
systems now the next thing we're going
to talk about is sort of large scale
changes um so being able to tell us that
a collection of work is able to a um is
equal to sort of a custom change type so
imagine that we have sort of a function
or a class called thingy which has this
concept of a multiply functionality um
we then have access to sort of the
notifiers we talked about earlier and
then we have this idea of sort of a
perform chains function which basically
lets us say well this is some large
piece of functionality and I want to be
able to describe this in terms that
other things can go and observe and then
I'm able to notify them about um
specific changes in a slightly more
controlled fashion the reason is objects
might want to be able to describe larger
semantic changes that might sort of uh
affect lots of different properties at
the same
time so we can actually go and take uh a
look sorry um we can actually go and
take a look at an example of this so uh
let me load this up uh this is actually
an implementation of exactly what we
were talking about just now um and the
idea is that we have sort of a thingy um
function and inside here we've uh
basically described a few different
things that you could observe uh some
multiply functionality increment
functionality um and here's our
increment function which has got a
Notifier inside of it and here's the
interesting part so we're saying okay
well perform a particular change we're
going to name that change um and this is
actually going to represent the amount
of work that has to be done um to go and
increment something we're then going to
go and use our Notifier um to tell the
system that this specific type of um
change has been made so an increment um
update has been made rather than just
saying you know something's been updated
because that actually ends up having
quite a lot more meaning to
people so um if we scroll through this
file you'll see that we've got a similar
setup for other things so mult multiply
and um and so on I've got a similar
setup and this is actually quite
interesting so take a look at thingy.
observe now this is once again using the
concept of an accept list so what we're
able to do is we're able to observe our
thingy we've got a call back and then
we're just able to specify that we're
only interested in these specific types
of changes so um whenever you're
incrementing multiplying you're
incrementing and multiplying or whenever
you're sort of going and you're
updating so we can do now we we're just
defining a new thingy with with the
values of two and four and we can go and
we can actually uh evaluate this in the
console so I'm just going to go and
evaluate this um and we can start
playing around so I can go and say okay
well thingy. increment by three so we
had two numbers remember we had two
numbers earlier so uh we sort of got two
uh change records for the two properties
that we updated which is sort of
expected um because we've got a generic
Observer set up for those and then we
have another Observer set up um which is
keeping an eye on these custom changes
so take a not look here at the fact that
we now have this custom type um that's
available for other people to go and
observe and if we expand the object
you'll see that it's correctly
incremented them um as we expected which
is pretty cool um we can actually prove
that this uh this sort of is just uh
limited to specific types of changes
here by going and incrementing b++ which
you'll notice um sort of increments B
with a normal um update type um but yeah
that works it's pretty neat um and we
can also go and do things like um
multiply inside the system um and also
get back sort of uh change reports that
are specific to multiplication so here
I'm just going to go and multiply by two
you'll see that we got two change
records for the normal update um and
then another change record with the type
multiply and uh the current state of our
system and our numbers is actually
exactly uh what we were expecting we
could continue playing around with this
if if we wanted now um another
interesting thing that object.observe
comes with um is the ability to observe
arrays so here I've got a very simple um
example I've got a few different uh
to-do items or whatever set up inside
our model um I'm able to use array.
observe to observe this model um and it
basically treats large scale changes to
itself like splice operations unshift or
or anything which implicitly changes its
length um is sort of a splice change
record uh so let's go and play around
with this so I'm going and I'm changing
the model a little bit I'm going to say
well skip this step um and basically
internally what this is doing is
actually just doing Notifier do perform
change with a type of splice so as you
can see um our view of the world is
exactly what we want want it to be which
is great um and this is just another
mechanism um array. observe actually
supports quite a few um other bits and
pieces that I sort of recommend you go
check
out now um people might be wondering
well who's actually the uh the audience
for for this who's the audience for
object. observe
um I I don't know whether or not to say
these are framework authors but um it's
unlikely that uh I guess app developers
um are going to want to directly use
object. observe you of course can if you
want you can get more than um welcome to
but it simply provides you sort of a
record of all the changes made inside
your system um it's more likely that
sort of JavaScript library vendors are
going to end up using this um and sort
of evolve what they have at the moment
to to sort of get some nice performance
improvements based on the fact that
you're using sort of a native primitive
rather than uh relying on things like
containment traps or dirty
checking um for people that are sort of
interested in uh trying object. obser
out in in other browsers uh Raphael
Weinstein um who uh who implemented
object. observe in V8 um actually went
and wrote a nice little shim or polyfill
for for the feature that you can go
check out on the polymer organization on
GitHub and you can do all sorts of
really nice things here so um it's sort
of sort like I said it's a polyfill for
object. observe gives you this nice
aggregate view of the world um it sort
of sums up all the different changes
that are uh made to your objects your
arrays and delivers you this nice sort
of report of what's changed now two
particularly interesting things that it
can do is sort of um observe paths so
you're able to say well I'm interested
in changes made to food. bar da and
it'll actually correctly deliver you um
all the different change records related
to that so paths are are something you
can also observe um it'll also tell you
about things like U I guess array
splices now an array splice I mentioned
the term earlier I probably should have
defined it um an array splice is
basically sort of the the minimal set of
splice operations you have to perform um
to sort of take an array and transform
the old version of it into the newer
version of it this is sort of a sort of
a transform view of that um that data
but um check out observe JS it's it's
actually quite cool
um My Hope Is that sort of uh object.
observe is is hopefully in time going to
land in more browsers for people
interested in trying it out in Chrome
Canary right now um you can go and you
can sort of enable experimental
JavaScript um in about flags and and
just start hacking on it right away um
we're hoping to put together sort of a
number of of really interesting examples
around this feature that you can check
out um if you are interested in polymer
which is sort of our framework for for
web components it's it's using object.
observe in a number of places and and
doing some really interesting things
there with it so uh I sort of recommend
checking that out it's pretty
neat um and yeah I hope to see object.
observed in more places uh so I think
that earlier I said that I would give
you a few stories about butterflies and
that's that's sort of how I'm going to
end things so um this is the story of
the pl of the butterfly now um in Old
England the the word butterfly in rather
Old English uh was butter fla or butter
FL um which breaks down into two words
so butter um which means to beat and FL
which means a fly and uh when I try
visualizing this mind probably because
I'm a silly person um this is this is
sort of the picture that I get it's it's
of this really poor guy being beaten
it's it's a little bit sad now the the
Russian for butterfly um is actually
boska is there anyone from Russia here
wow I'm sorry for sort of just like
bashing your language I'm terrible at it
um I probably pronounced it all sorts of
wrong um but the uh the Russian for
butterflies but bka and I think that it
also translates to sort of some sort of
FFF fly um but it also means bow tie so
you have this this pretty sexy looking
guy here with a bow tie um and uh and
finally um in devire in the UK back in
sort of olden times they were extremely
superstitious and so they'd actually all
go out and kill the first butterfly of
the season for for good luck and my
visualization of that is is pretty much
um this which is just very very
sad um I think the the morale of the
story is that people are crazy um okay
okay uh so that is it for object.observe
I hope that you're as excited about the
feature as I am I'm very very hopeful
that the platform of tomorrow is going
to to solve more and more of the
problems that we've had to implement
solutions for ourselves over the past
few years and uh with that thank
you thanks Addie um so before we launch
into questions uh there has been an
iPhone turned into me so if you've lost
an iPhone come over to me and if you can
describe the iPhone reasonably I will
return it to you so with that any
questions for
Addie no no uh
than so was the the template that was
described there um is that all Native or
was that provided by the the framework
you were so the idea is that so that was
provided that's basically um being
powered by polyfill at the moment and
the idea is that eventually that'll find
its way into Chrome and other browsers
it's sort of part of the platform of
Tomorrow one more anybody oh there's one
over
there does object.observe have any
implications for V8 optimizations sorry
can you repeat that does object.observe
have any implications for V8
optimizations um actually so so object
the current implementation of
object.observe um has got quite a long
way to go in terms of the optimizations
performance optimizations that need to
be made um we've already seen uh quite
uh a few good cases where it outperforms
dirty checking um quite heavily um for
its particular use cases but I think
that the next few months we'll probably
see a lot more optimization
work